I was a Nova Festival uh we dance we
kind of have fun you know it's a
electronic Festival everybody comes to
enjoy and be together then you know the
missile started we didn't hear the alarm
first cuz they didn't turn off the music
a few minutes after the the first
missiles the turn off the music and then
you know they started yelling just run
take everything you have on you and just
run you know it's like 3,000 people
running away you don't really see
nothing you just run run people falling
I fell down and then I got up and uh a
friend saw me just emerged uh from the
Cars he took me and he told me come on
we have to go uh he was very paranoid so
uh lucky for me
uh because of him we we we we've been
able to get to a car uh really fast we
start driving we just ran away from
there we didn't stop we saw a few
terrorists uh knocked on the ground and
I think the first people that uh went
off the party they they they had a uh
they didn't survive cu the terrorist
came and the second wave that uh went
off the party was was okay but everyone
that left uh stay there uh got
slaughtered we thought it just okay it's
regular missiles it's it's in the south
of Israel uh they get missiles all the
time um they suffer from this like 20
years and we thought it's a regular
scenario which uh few missiles going up
and then it's going to stop in a few
minutes and and the part is going to
keep going but it's not the same uh we
saw we saw those parachutes in the sky
and we understood it's a very very hard
scenario uh people that are you know ran
away they understood what kind of
scenario it
is I can describe the feeling because
you know you're kind of you're running
away I was not scared I think only after
I realize in in what kind of uh uh event
or thing I was then I
was I still didn't I I still wasn't
afraid
but I was shocked
it's the first time it happens in
[Music]
Israel I think that the people that saw
those forces did not survive because
they came with a truck loaded with
terrorist they didn't like came two
people and then you know you can see
them they came full full like six or
seven people on trucks and tens of tens
of trucks uh uh that rushed into the
parties and to the kibuts near the party
I think that they didn't really know
about the party they just found out
about it and it was like I'm sorry I I
don't want to say it but it sounds like
jackpot for
them we had to leave right now you
cannot stop you saw those trucks you
cannot stop the people who stopped got
uh shots to their uh cars a few of them
really survived few of them don't since
there's a lot of dead people you heard
uh you're still hearing stories about
those people and those kid the people
that got kidnapped you still hear about
them I don't think it's going to uh it's
going to end soon um I feel like I'm in
a ongoing event since I came home I took
my stuff I got on a my my I took my
equipment and then went to straight to
the Army to finish this I was uh running
at first but now we're going to we're
going to fight against
them so I went back home I tried to
contact my my B commander and tell them
the story you understood I took one day
off and then I I went to the Army you
have to do it as quick as you can it's
if don't I think I think I'll have a a
ongoing
trauma but now this is this is the
healing process for
me you cannot really get mourn because
you have to wait until everything is
over it's not over for us for me it
didn't over it's still ongoing uh until
it's really over and then we're going
to we're going to see all the uh
families of our lost friends and we're
going to mourn on them but as for now we
have to fight back we have to be strong
we have to we have to take care of our
families and the rest of the rest people
of Israel um you cannot show weakness
right now there's no weakness we have to
be strong very strong I don't feel any
any weakness I have the friends here I
have my Army friends uh you share with
them a few of the stories just to you
know to get it out and it feels good
feels good to get it out and it makes
you stronger it makes us stronger
time we came to a party we came to have
fun to dance to feel the love and the
Vibes and this terror attack was
horrified but horrible but now we are
strong we took our stuff we took our
weapons and and we're going to fight
back now there's no running uh at first
we were running but now there's no
running